[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle saison de
paf avec des intervenants que vous
connaissez bien et qu'ils seront là tout
au long de cette année comme jean
charles lajoie dit bonjour bonjour et
éditeurs je vais vous né comme chaque
fois j'avais toujours quand même mais
quasiment chaque fois avec avec un
cadeau alors ouais ça c'est un titre je
sais pas si c'est un bon titre pour ne
sautez pas ouidane au sénat ça n'a rien
à voir l'actualité brûlante de lire non
non c'est une sautée pas c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune laveur de carreaux
qui expose de plein de questions
existentielles sur son toit et puis un
jour il mange son sandwich chaud ou du
plus haut building de bruxelles est un
type qui se précipitent vers luisants de
sauter pas ne sautez pas pensant que le
cas là ça lui suffit d et ça lui donne
l'idée se dit de d'essayer de soutirer
de l'argent aux multinationales en
faisant des sorte de chantage comme ça
et voilà le livre démarre à ce moment là
c'est de frédéric r note qui n'a rien à
voir rien à voir avec la patronne de
france télévisions c'est un jeune auteur
belge très a appelé un grand avenir une
très très belle plume très bien donc ça
s'appelle mieux c'était des sites aux
éditions évidemment la joie voilà
stéphane minson bonjour bonjour patrice
professeur à l'université et jour de
versailles saint quentin mais pas très
loin il ya aucune raison l'argent là
universitaire à leur traitement c'est
n'en ressentent hui tout ce sont que 9
ans alain plein temps la rentrée s'est
bien déroulé sauf qu'elle s'est déroulé
le 1er septembre figurez-vous marahoué
tout fout le camp pour ce qui se passe
voilà tout universitaire entre le jour 2
même jour que les classes travaillent et
non ses débuts des records sa patrie ça
pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus qu'une trois heures
de cours par semaine comme autrefois
nous reparlerons oui
quand je me dis que tu es 5 en jeu ce
n'est pas une plaisanterie laurence père
qu'avez-vous jour avocat trio barreau de
versailles est de savoir vie pour cette
première de cette saison d'avoir un
invité et pas n'importe quelle vérité
c'est karl olive maire de poissy conseil
général vice président du conseil
général et vous publiez un livre et qui
s'appelle ma ville ma bataille c'est aux
éditions balland
et c'est un livre absolument
j'étais bouleversé extraordinaire je
trouve pas ce que c'est ça change
totalement de tous les livres politiques
on peut lire avec des idées plus
générale la vous raconter ce que c'est
quotidiennement la vie d'un maire
comment ça se passe comment on prépare
les conseils municipaux quelles
questions vous posiez la question
absolument incroyable il ya un joueur un
type qui vous qui vient de voir dans un
magasin qui vit dit écoutez ma fille a
ses règles il
ya toutes sortes de questions il ya
aussi des expériences que vous avez
menées notamment sur la façon dont les
d'aider des gens de la fonction
municipale peuvent quitter leur leur
emploi
donc voilà c'est un livre la sélection
dit est ce que c'est la première
question que vous avez posé parce que
c'est vrai que à barkin critique très
forte de la ville de la classe politique
est ce que c'est une façon pour vous de
répondre à cette critique en montrant ce
qu'est au four la vie quotidienne d'un
élu d'abord bonjour monsieur carmouze
bonjour bonjour a tous je veux juste
vous dire de ceux qui refusent que j'ai
la chance pour la première fois de
partager avec vous un studio télé et que
quand j'étais gamin on vous regardait la
télé alors il peut vous caresser des
lapins des cochons vous en car et c'est
peut-être plus mais vous avez une autre
tangente en voilà c'est moi donc c'est
ce que je voulais vous dire eux non pour
tout vous dire je me suis pas du tout
occupé de ce qui se passait à
l'extérieur c'est juste un constat
aujourd'hui il ya 84 4 14% des
administrés qui rejette la classe
politique française de gauche comme de
droite et l'idée c'est de pouvoir
rapprocher comment rapprocher l'élu de
l'administrer autant qu'ils s'éloignent
aujourd'hui et je pense que ça vient du
terrain et de façon pragmatique moi j'ai
pas de codes politiques je suis entré en
politique en 2008 j'étais lui en 2014
mais j'ai démarré on va revenir à boire
c'est un petit peu l'idée est ici je
dirais que voilà il ya des clés de
démocratie de proximité d'outils
démocratie de proximité et le sérum de
la vérité c'est les élections
intermédiaires
62% élections municipales au premier
tour et 82% sur poissy donc je me dis
que c'est quelque chose qui peut
fonctionner j'essaye d'être jugant dans
la transmission ablement et je pense que
ça peut fonctionner c'était en tout cas
le message que j'envoie travers de cet
ouvrage est à peu près le même score
pour votre réélection
oui c'était 82 à 78 % sur l'ensemble des
14 qui est quand même un des cinq
sections et c'était votre première
candidature évidemment à la mairie de
poissy enfin on va savourer revenir un
mot quand même sur justement sur la vie
de mai alors que vous êtes extrêmement
présent vous allez balle comme alors on
voit souvent les hommes politiques sur
les marchés vous expliquer pourquoi il
faut y aller comment on fait pourquoi
c'est là où qu'on a le contact avec la
population qu'on a le retour de ce
qu'ils ressentent pas ce que j'explique
surtout que les marchés c'est pas 15
jours avant l'élection et quinze jours
six n'ont pas fait finalement le bureau
c'est le terrain parce que on peut avoir
comme comme des collègues d'ailleurs de
gauche comme de droite un des des plages
horaires les mardis matin les mercredis
matin pour accueillir des administrés
moi je m'aperçois que quand on accueille
un administré d'une demi heure mais
quand on est sur le terrain sur les
marchés dans les quartiers on va
répondre aux mêmes questions en 10
minutes et toujours un collaborateur une
collaboratrice de cabinet qui
m'accompagnent on prend les coordonnées
on prend la question et le surlendemain
le ou parfois le jour même la question
n'est on y répond en général c'est une
demande de logement en général s'il
s'agit de propreté urbaine d'incivilité
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui ce qui
ce travail sur le terrain et je pense
que l'une des clés de la réussite entre
papa la réussite mais en tout cas l'une
des clefs de salut sur ces outils de
proximité vous l'avez dit c'est vraiment
l'engagement terrain nous on en a marre
franchement de se voir infuser des
choses qui nous viennent depuis le
sommet d'en haut sans aucune
concertation auprès de la base c'est ça
nous par tout cas moi je je c'est
insupportable on pourrait prendre plein
de sujets
notamment le dernier en date c'est la
réforme des collèges ou aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que les enseignants eux mêmes
n'ont pas été concertés on est mis
devant un fait accompli ça c'est
insupportable
voilà humblement on essaye avec notre
équipe parce que c'est pas l'histoire
d'un bonhomme c'est l'histoire d'une
équipe de 32 et air
sol terrain à faire remonter des
informations et d'être en adéquation
avec ce que souhaitent les administrés
qui sont pour nous voilà le seul souci
entre guillemets au quotidien c'est à
dire ni des relais maire a frôlé ça
quand même parmi les hommes politiques
c'est ceux qui sont les mieux considérés
dans la dans le lot les sondages est
encore un îlot de faim de popularité
relative oui mais sur le terrain c'est
pas toujours cela enfin tout dépend des
communes tout dépend des mères mais
c'est vrai que c'est sans doute l'élu
c'est l'élu de proximité par excellence
mais ça aussi son revers c'est à dire
que je pense que ça a dû vous arrivez
sur les marchés
d'avoir à vous expliquer d'avoir les
comptes à rendre c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est pas un mandat un mandat
facile je sais pas s'il ya des mandats
facilement fin de mandat de
parlementaire est nécessairement plus +
éloize un bar d'or à plein temps de
pose de vraies questions
notamment celle de la
professionnalisation des mandats
c'est vrai vous avez raison sur le sur
le terrain oui c'est pas une c'est pas
toujours une partie de plaisir mais
enfin on a été aussi élu pour ça
impossible par exemple pour aller dans
votre sens on prépare nos conseils
municipaux dans les quartiers je pense
qu on est la seule commune de france à
le faire sûr que tous les tous les mois
on prépare nos conseils municipaux dans
un quartier différent on prévient les
administrés une semaine avant c'est
entre 200 et 400 pendant deux heures on
discute avec eux et là je peux vous dire
que c'est pas une partie de plaisir
parce qu'on en prend plein la figure et
régis cléon propria les griffes comme on
dit au rugby mais les administrés ont
des réponses facebook et y soient là
vraiment de visu et puis si moi je n'ai
pas la réponse et ça peut arriver mon
collègue et lui peut la voir le chef de
service parce que les chefs de service
sont présents et puis le partenaire le
promoteur immobilier l'agencé postale je
pense à cet exemple là est aussi
présente le cas échéant selon
l'actualité et les admirer les
administrés ressortent avec des réponses
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
administrés sont capables de tout
entendre que c'est possible et que ce
n'est pas possible et que ce nice si
c'est pas possible on puisse leur
expliquer pourquoi c'est parce que
possible parce que qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui malheureusement on
n'est pas dans un pays où en est on
applique les règles mais on les
interprète avec un laxisme qui tenta à
faire en sorte que ba notre société tout
aujourd'hui dans dans ce laxisme là
quand on donne les règles qu'on fixe les
règles et qu'on respecte ses règles à un
moment donné on est dans le jeu on est
hors du jeu et quand on est hors du jeu
il faut le dire et les administrés
l'entendent comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le sérum de vérité c'est les
élections intermédiaires ça fonctionne
plutôt bien et je me dis que si ça
fonctionne à poissy il ya d'autres
endroits où ça peut aussi bien
fonctionné et là on dépasse les clivages
je pense gauche droite je prends souvent
le cas de dijon chez françois rebsamen
qui est qui et sénateurs de gauche
l'ancien ministre et ça fonctionne aussi
très bien comme le dit vivre à dijon
demain moi je le dis je voterai rebsamen
oui c'est ça c'est pour ça que disent
les vives est assez originale parce que
c'est pas un livre d'idéologues à un
livre de politique pratique c'est aussi
alors la ville c'est aussi un lieu où on
peut faire aussi d'aider des expériences
à des expérimentations et vous en faites
oui patrice parce que comme le dit
le gérard larcher le président du sénat
qui m'a qui m'a offert la préface c'est
cette génération a connu l'âge d'or nous
on est à l'âge de pierre l'âge de pierre
parce qu'on a une nécessaire
restructuration évidente des finances
publiques etc aujourd'hui par rapport à
cela il faut innover il faut être
imaginatif et parfois faux faut oser
innover c'est quoi c'est par exemple
mutualiser des services de la mairie où
nous étions dans des bâtiments
locataires vers des services où nous
sommes propriétaires cinq cent mille
euros d'économies mais c'est allé puiser
dans une source de la ville pour
récupérer cette eau qui est qui n'est
pas potable mais qui peut servir à la
propreté urbaine et ses vingt mille
euros d'économies c'est aussi proposer
quand je dit choqué entre guillemets un
plan de départs volontaires puisque moi
quand je suis arrivé dans cette ville
avec mes collègues en gros la strate
pour lui le com de com voici quarante
mille habitants c'est entre 750 et 800
agents quand je suis arrivé à 1053 gens
donc et qui font très bien leur boulot
il n'empêche que sur une ville moyenne
devrait être entre 750 et 800 il y avait
pour exister par le volontaire alors
c'est pour d'abord je l' ai connu à
cannes et plus et un jour un jeune
garçon mais moi je suis du sud et je le
disais tout à l'heure dans la coulisse
je suis né dans les quartiers dans un
quartier populaire qui s'appelle la
coudraie un jeune un jeune de mes potes
est venu voir kate agents syndiqués cgt
me dit voilà moi j'aimerais j'aimerais
partir de la collectivité parce que j'ai
un projet mais j'aurais partis avec un
peu d'argent de la relance j ecoute moi
j'ai connu ça canal mais dans le domaine
public ça n'existe pas j je vais
regarder et ça existe depuis le 18
décembre 2009 il ya un arrêté à la
demande de l'agent avec un projet validé
par par le maire selon son ancienneté il
peut partir entre avec 15 milles entre
15000 et 60000 euros alors point noir
est pourquoi depuis 2009 perd ce
versement fait parce que c'est pas
politiquement correct mais quand vous
expliquer ça d'autant que c'est à
l'initiative de l'agent ça fonctionne et
valérie pécresse quelques autres vos
collègues donc voila voila les pécresse
quelques mois vrai nous a demandé les
éléments et c'est pour pouvoir
éventuellement le mettre en place à la
région ile-de-france mais le collègue
maire de maubeuge a fait la même chose
j'ai reçu des lettres de 2,2 france
entière parce qu'évidemment ça fait le
buzz en faisant il fait un plan social
et c'est pas du tout pas du tout plaider
la démence il réside et l'agencé de
volontaires voilà voilà
et c'est oser innover et puis parfois où
il choqué quand on travaille sur
l'absentéisme des choses qui font pas
toujours plaisir alors autre chose avant
de revenir peut-être un peu sur votre
parcours mais c'est quelque chose qui
fait polémique c'est la lettre que vous
aviez envoyé au médecin sur les arrêts
de travail parce que vous êtes rendu
compte que les arrêts de travail qui
était donné dans la fonction publique
était beaucoup plus long que dans le
privé vous aviez écrit au médecin en
disant peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose
qui cloche peut-être qu'il faut faire
attention et alors ça va sauver une
polémique les médecins ont dit mais
comment qu'est ce que c'est que c'est un
peu geeks mère qui s'en prend à la
liberté des médecins et là vous devrez
expliquer ça et au fond on se dit qu'il
a raison et en fait je pense qu'une
partie des médecins parce que c'est une
flowline frange très sincère qui avait
fait polémique c'est une frange très
généraliste qui s'étaient émus en fait
on est tous aujourd'hui de gauche comme
de droite concernés quand on est élu
responsable sur les restructurations des
finances publiques on a plus de 2000
milliards de dettes dans ce pays donc
chacun son endroit on essaie d'être
responsable on a mis en place un
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
par quoi elle passe elle passe notamment
par je dirais un meilleur vivre de la
part des agents et j'ai simplement
expliqué aux médecins dans cette lettre
si vous pensez que l'agent qui vient
vous voir à une pathologie direct en
lien avec son travail alors si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez le diriger vers la
médecine préventive qui est pas une
médecine communal médecine indépendante
qui est à même à juger si effectivement
l'arrêt de travail potentiel est
justifiée ou non voilà ce que j'ai dit
et ce qui est pour moi confine à
améliorer la qualité la qualité du
travail alors les médecins évidemment
enfants debout et puis j'ai commencé une
fois que les médecins ont bien compris
qu'ils m'ont permis de faire le tour des
plateaux pour pour expliquer ce que vous
venez de deux parfaitement explicite et
patrice mais ils ont compris que ma
démarche n'était pas du pas du tout de
la vraiment leur liberté au delà de la
frange de cette la preuve vous mettre à
leur place c'est que les mêmes médecins
qui me guèye qui me prenait la gérance
sont venus me voir pour me demander
comment on pouvait travailler ensemble
pour lutter contre la désertification
médicale et on va mettre en place dès
mai 18 des maisons médicalisées et
mettre en place des cabinets de médecine
parce qu'aujourd'hui avec les normes
cher aujourd'hui pour les médecins d'une
certaine génération ça coûte des
centaines de milliers d'euros et on est
dans cet accompagnement donc je suis
ravi de pouvoir citer les chiffres
d'ailleurs ça me passe de six journaux
privés 20 jours dans le public en gros
après si on est à peu près à 20 jours
d'arrêt de travail par agents vont
multiplier en gros par mille agents ça
fait vingt mille 20 mille jours dans le
privé ces dix jours et à la moyenne
nationale dans les collectivités
publiques ses 22 jours alors vous allez
me roux aimé vous êtes en sous le
maillot national et alors on peut pas
faire mieux c'est ça l'idée et ça
correspond à 2 million à 2 millions
d'euros 2 millions d'euros impacté à un
million cinq cent mille directement sur
la collectivité contrairement à ce qu'on
entend ou c'est la sécu pas du tout un
million cinq cent mille pour pour la
collectivité donc je pense qu'avec
simplement un ou deux jours de moins on
fait le calcul ces deux cent mille euros
et 200 mille euros c'est presque c'est
presque trois postes à plein temps pour
pour troisième ministre et pour pardon
pour trois agents donc c'est pareil
c'est pas mal comme une épopée qui a pas
de petites économies vous avez de bonnes
références donc ma ville ma bataille aux
éditions balland lé mobile devient un
petit peu sur votre parcours parce que
vous êtes en effet un vous l'avez dit un
gamin poids si vous avez été attiré
assez tôt par les médias puisque vous
avez parti viv les c'était le début des
radios locales nous avait 13 ou 14 ans
week-end sur cette radio locale et puis
il ya la création divine première par
michel péricard et vous entrez dans
yvelines première et là c'est marrant
parce qu'il est toujours dans les vies
un moment où ça bascule et là il ya vous
avez une idée de faire une émission sur
le paris saint germain et vous
rencontrer évidemment tous les joueurs
les entraîneurs michel denisot et c'est
comme ça que vous allez entrer à canal+
oui enfin déjà patrice leleu le football
chez chez nous travaillons vous êtes
juste vous a fait voir vos enfants
jouent très bien on était huit dans
notre dos l'autre femme et mes cinq
frères
professionnel j'ai une soeur cry qui a
réussi est professionnel donc les atouts
à la praire des habsbourg les plus
fiables on a cru paris saint germain et
c'est donc effectivement quand on est
gamin qu'on veut est journaliste sportif
et qu'on rencontre un jour michel
denisot avec lequel on a rêvé de
travailler c'est juste le bonheur en
plus c'est la passion du ballon rond et
puis petit à petit voilà dans la
proximité denisot vous connaissez comme
moi étaient vraiment
un homme vrai fait que ben jour il m'a
dit viens viens poser le micro sur le
terrain puisque tu connais le ballon et
puis voilà comment l'aventuré a commencé
en 1981 il est devenu directeur d'action
et directeur des sports de canal plus
vous créez les stores sur itélé ensuite
et puis un jour vous dites bon elle vous
êtes quand même dommage tout va très
bien au point de vue professionnel et
vous arrêtez tout en disant moi ce que
je veux c'est revenir à poissy et s'est
occupée vous savez comment s'appelle
capitaux dont voici la gelée sua je les
subis ça m'échappe je crois que d'une
bêtise nord flore
bonne question les pisciacais
pisciacais mois d avril à tort
j'ai entendu il ya une petite semaine
pendant le jeu des mille francs sur
france inter mais j'avais peur de
lewy de jeu des mille euros
[Rires]
et les boxeurs mais cédric et vous avez
quand même eu toujours cette envie de
dormir
dira voilà où vous êtes vous avez grandi
oui en fait je suis jamais jamais jamais
de martin on avait un petit fois ci
il ya eu les lumières de paris voudrait
la lune la transposition par rapport à
cela c'est que quand on joue au ballon
quand on est môme un ça va très vite on
est dans une vraie belle mixité sociale
qu'on a complètement raté alors là les
et on est tous responsables
les bailleurs les aménageurs les élus de
gauche comme de droite on a raté cette
mixité mois juste pour l'anecdote mais
quand dans les années 70 on était au
pied de nos tours dans le quartier
populaire de la coudraie y avait des
espagnols des portugais des turcs eux
des bretons comme ma maman voilà est
aujourd'hui à puce a aujourd'hui vous
avez des colonnes de rock indé colonnes
d'algériens des colonnes de turc si ça
c'est de la mixité sociale moi je sors
je n'accepte pas ça est oublié nous en
sommes responsables voilà mais je pense
que pour le coup voilà on jouait tous
ensemble et moi j'ai comme je dis j'ai
toujours aimé l'autre j'ai toujours été
en contact avec l'autre et je pense que
pour le politique
la base principale c'est quand même
d'aimer les gens et ça ça passe ça
s'apprend pas dans l'ex-zone air qu'on
fasse du journalisme comme vous quand
vous êtes en contact avec l'autre c'est
pas une flagornerie que dire que vous
avez un contact privilégié patrice
carmouze avec eux avec votre auditoire
quand on est dans la politique quand on
est dans le sport il ya une chose c'est
le respect la valorisation et j'irai
l'amitié le nom des gens voilà et déjà
on vous ai entendu mais vous êtes revenu
par l'associatif alors vous avez présidé
le
poissy
et et puis on va je suis revenu pouces
il voulait pour une bonne raison vous
avez un coeur de poissy et aux
aspirations s'est pas directement la
politique mais non moi je suis en
politique j'ai vécu deux engagés du jour
au lendemain ou à la fin du premier tour
de l'élection municipale de 2008 j'étais
président du club de l'ès pressing et
j'ai toujours été non pas soutenu mais
j'ai eu toujours un espèce de supporters
qui était le maire qui ne me souvenais
qui ne connaissait absolument rien au
football qui m'a laissé tranquille il
m'a dit simplement faut bien gérer les
deniers publics je crois l'avoir fait
entre 2004 et 2008 ce maire a été ennuyé
par la justice donc il a eu ce qui
malheureusement bien été mais il m'a il
m'a soutenu et moi je le jeu le
soutenait aussi dans sa campagne il
trouve que j'étais présente son comité
de soutien et quant au premier tour il a
fait 42 % et que la gauche a fait 27 et
le modem 26 et que le modem le modem
était brûlé au modem de centre-droit
donc c'était l'alliance dont le carpe et
du lapin quand le modem et la gauche et
les verts et les communistes sont passés
au second tour vous avez démissionné
j'ai tout de suite démissionné c'était
pour moi impossible d'être finalement le
philippe noiret du vieux fusil face au
niveau mer egée j'ai expliqué que cette
alliance contre nature allait droit dans
le mur on est au bout de quelques mois
il y avait déjà des grosses difficultés
au sein même de l'église saint
léger donc tout de suite créé cette
association étaient cinq au départ on
était 300 l'arrivée et on est allé à la
rencontre des gens pour cette
association voilà qui vous a permis de
vous étiez évidemment connu parce que
vous étiez président des
fois ci mais mais mais mais mais et
c'est vrai qu'il va laisser un
sous-préfet que vous avez dit mais vous
avez pourquoi vous prenez pas la ville
est à vous parce que vous aviez cette
notoriété la met mais quand même vous
êtes parti de l'associatif vous ai pas
je veux dire par là quand vous êtes
présenté aujourd'hui vous êtes vous êtes
banque du parti républicain oui mais
vous n'étiez pas recours à du tout
présenté
vous avez été soutenu par eux vous avez
fait une bonne à dire que quand j'étais
à la direction des sports de canal+ j'ai
accueilli david douillet avec ni un
jeune retraité qui venait de remporter
le titre de champion olympique david est
arrivé en 2009 à poissy a été élu à la
législative et on a fait je dirais
girerd autres communes
effectivement j'étais sans étiquette à
l'époque et j'ai rejoint ce mouvement dé
l'ump puis des républicains tout
simplement parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas être à la fois dans
l'assistanat complet alors que l'on peut
être dans l'accompagnement on peut pas
donner à manger du poisson tous les
jours quand on est capable d'apprendre à
pêcher voilà je suis plus dans cette
droite sociale aux miséreux mondiale et
ouais je sais bien mais j'assume
alors voici voit plus grand et ça c'est
quelque chose que vous venez de lancer
dans votre émission avec moi qui parle
patrice non
si vous avez des questions vous pouvez
intervenir pour vous les timides
heureusement qu'il prend soin de vous
mais on va après avoir on va parler un
peu de politique générale vous allez
voir à mon avis donnés les marques
célèbres robes jupes
poissy voit plus grand non je dis ça
parce qu'on on est toujours dans
l'actualité du paris saint-germain
puisque le paris saint germain va revoir
son là vous posez pouvoir intervenir
sauf que là ce centre d'entraînement
après si ça y est c'est fait ça sera en
2000 le premier premiers travaux début
d'année prochaine ouverture potentielle
à la rentrée 2010 9 en fait c'est une
semaine historique que la ville de
poissy a vécu puisque le 11 juillet nous
avons eu la décision du paris
saint-germain devenir s'installe à pau 6
75 hectares et le 18 juillet nous avons
il annonce de l'unesco de l'inscription
au patrimoine de l'unesco de notre vie
l'alcool musée avec sa voix on a eu
vraiment voilà deux comètes qui se son
voile a déployé sur la cité pisciacaise
alors à moutier sur le paris
saint-germain moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt suis plutôt une bonne nouvelle
j'imagine qu'à saint germain on est un
peu grise mine parce que le loin des
salles paris poissy mais voilà le nom
même
mais ça coince un peu logique paris
saint germain pour la à poissy
maintenant moi ça me paraît quand même
plus logique que d'aller à grignon qui
était quand même assez loin fallait
faire une demi autoroute pour que les
joueurs puissent se sortir
tranquillement donc voilà c'est bien
est-ce que les est ce que le projet est
aussi pharaonique qu'il était à grignon
vous ça va être très très bon un très
bel établissement un truc spécial redit
que je connais absolument pas le projet
qui était celui de grignon l'at il été
un jour j'en suis pas convaincu ce que
je sais c'est qu'on a toujours nous
focaliser notre énergie sur le projet de
poissy qui d'ailleurs au départ était
pas celui du paris saint germain était
un pôle régional du loisir sportif dédié
aux familles que nous portions avec
david douillet et puis et vous l'avez
dit le berceau du paris saint germain
c'est saint germain en laye d'ailleurs
on voit bien le le sig rappelant le
berceau louis xiv maintenant comme je
les dis si pour des raisons qu'ils
appartiennent aux dirigeants du paris
saint germain l'idée était de trouver un
autre terrain d'entraînement alors oui
on aura été d idiot quand on est
passionné celui par exemple quand on a
travaillé dans le sport comme david
douillet avec l'appui du président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier le
consensus des sculpteurs ne pas proposer
voilà cette plaine de 75 hectares et
surtout un projet social dire que là je
pense que le choix du paris saint
germain était de 2-2 ordre soit
reproduire clairefontaine
c'est à dire un grand bain grand et beau
projet la petite maison dans la prairie
ou alors faire quelque chose un peu plus
de périurbain plus sociale moi c'est ce
que j'ai en tout cas souhaité avec les
dirigeants du paris saint germain pour
qu'on soit vraiment dans ce que
j'appelle le cercle vertueux de
l'économie locale c'est à dire que les
1000 personnes qui vont travailler
pendant deux ans je souhaite qu'elles
soient recrutés dans la communauté
urbaine grand paris c'est noah c'est à
dire poissy et alentours qu'ensuite les
sans emploi pérenne de la même manière
qu'ils aient des circuits courts par
exemple en termes d'agriculture qu'on
puisse offrir aux aujourd'hui paris
saint-germain des fruits et légumes
qu'ils soient
choisis dans les vergers du coin et ses
bureaux nommé pour pour la ville c'est
extraordinaire bien l'âme accélérateur
de particules tories y était
fait mention va se mettre au foot mais
il faudrait que la fin du monde à risque
j'aime bien quand le ballon est un peu
plus mal j'ai pas tout avec la tension
on vous dit que c'est un projet social
qu auparavant vous aviez un projet pour
faire un parc sportif pour les familles
ce qui va y avoir une partie de ce
terrain qui peut être ouvert où ça est
complètement psg 100 % et 100 % privé l
angoisse et sociale en dehors du fait
qu'ils vont ça c'est que le alors duras
il y aura un stade qui est prévu de 5000
places qui sera accessible il sera fermé
voilà aux associations il ya aussi un
travail qui sera fait que la fondation
du paris saint germain c'est en ce sens
où je trouve que le projet et social
avec des retombées économiques on peut
estimer de l'ordre de 2 millions d'euros
alors qu'ils n'auront pas dans
l'escarcelle de la ville de pau c'est
seulement mais dans l'escarcelle de la
commune urbaine on est devant sur une
mutualisation autour des 73 communes et
des 400 5000 habitants après oui en
terme de notoriété je dirais que on est
au delà évidemment de la ville de poissy
ça devient vraiment le deux thèmes de la
vallée de seine le totem de notre
communauté urbaine à vingt minutes du
parc des princes aux portes de paris je
pense que c'est vraiment une zone de
chalandise pour pouvoir accueillir des
sièges d'entreprises pour pouvoir
accueillir peut-être de nouveaux
commerces de proximité peut-être
quelques joueurs qui vont venir
s'installer en matière d'emploi s'il a
déjà sur la commune de possibles à des
jarrets et puis surtout de travailler
sur effectivement le commerce de
proximité je pense que c'est aussi un
facteur d'attractivité économique
grignoux le projet a capoté pour des
problèmes environnementaux notamment
pour l'histoire d'un champignon
prose il avait raison de le dire parce
que je mets ça a été bloquée une
traîtresse que les habitants sont
immédiatement c'est l'oppression ans a
[Musique]
vraiment un peuplier levé par par les
habitants alors que
peut-être même qu'il y avait aucun ne
le vous êtes attentifs à au problème
environnemental justement parce que 75
hectares c'est quand même oui notamment
par rapport à ce que je joue je vous
disais tout à l'heure m c'est à dire que
on est vraiment pour pour le circuit
court et ça c'est un travail en
collaboration directe avec les tuiles en
terme de travaux parce que vous allez
devoir à 75 ha je passe à se positionne
blagnacois y ait des chances
non on est sur une zone en fait on est
vraiment sur des terres qui avait été
acheté par unibail rodamco pour faire un
gigantesque centre commercial de 55
mille mètres carrés auxquels j'ai mis
j'ai mis fin élever la dette de la ville
de pau et si à l'époque était passé à 12
millions donc racheté par
l'établissement public foncier d'île de
france anciennement et fuit depuis le 20
et puis et fiche maintenant depuis le
1er janvier 2016 ce qui n'est permis de
lever la tête pour les pour les
pisciacais et derrière de revendre à
l'euro puisque c'est le prix des
domaines on est dans le domaine public
en fait à aller le fif qui lui-même a
vendu ensuite au paris saint germain
donc on est vraiment là sur les arcanes
administratives avec un travail
franchement formidable de la part à la
fois des agents techniques de la ville
de poissy des techniciens de les filles
mais aussi du département de la
communauté urbaine et du paris saint
germain ça vraiment été un travail
d'équipé on en parle parfois mais c'est
vrai que seul on va plus vite et
qu'ensemble on va plus loin là c'est
vraiment une démonstration par la preuve
alors un goût puisque vous êtes space de
foot puis sur charles aussi mais cette
saison du paris saint germain est là
vous la voyez comment parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de doutes et des gens qui
commencent à dire ouh là là je pense
qu'on est là on est un peu à non pas un
tournant de l'histoire ce serait un bien
grand mot mais depuis quatre ans le
paris saint germain est champion de
france très facilement avec des stars
renommée il ya eu par l'état
l'année dernière c'était la tan la star
l'an passé c'était de la tan cette année
la star c'est l'équipe donc c'est plus
homogène faut que ça se mettre en place
le les dirigeants du paris saint germain
et là on doit saluer le travail de
laurent blanc jusqu'à présent quatre
fois champion de france les dirigeants
du paris saint germain ont choisi un
technicien ibérique qui a fait ses
preuves qui étaient les deux fois ou
trois fois envoie en finale enfin gagné
trois fois gagnant final de l'enfant en
ligue europa donc aujourd'hui l'objectif
c'est de passer ces quarts de finale
pour arriver au moins me fait confiance
à moins que par principe je suis
confiant patrie de travail entraîne le
talent et elle entraîne réussite et je
sais qu'ils bossent beaucoup et oui on
reverra un cerveau c'est vrai et on le
verra ce soir contre les verts suis très
confiant mais je rejoins un petit peu
karl parce que moi je trouve qu'il
manque un platane cette année
une équipe c'est très bien mais c'est
bien lancé quatre ans leader c'est bien
mais c'est une superstar qui est qui qui
attire mais même sur le jeu parce que
cela t'a de même quantité n'est pas en
forme il avait deux ou trois joueurs qui
s'occupait que de lui alors que la star
allait pas ça allait briser
d'entre elles n'existaient pas ou il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent cavani va
prendre cette classe très nettement on
peut penser que nous sommes pas
demandeurs il peut prendre la place
d'avoir centimes donc non franchement
j'ai l'impression qu'il manque côte avec
une véritable force après tout c'est la
4e journée ce soir c'est saint-etienne
qui se dirait ce mardi à mardi yahia
sénat la
musique s'arrêtera donc là on invente un
petit peu brillant est vraiment
intéressant à suivre donc ça va être ça
va être amusant non mais quand on
perturbe les équilibres ce qui est le
cas puisque l'équipe a été quand même
très modifiée il faut qu'il retrouve un
nouvel équilibre qu'ils apprennent à
rejouer ensemble et peut-être que
quelqu'un naturellement ressortira du
lot je supporte plus mal soit six
premiers des biens et pendant
je mets typiquement 33 points
alors on va passer à peu à la politique
parce que à bas vous en fait quand même
même si vous êtes d'abord un élu local
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez des
ambitions autres aucune hockey n'ont
jamais membre est un peu malheureuse
rda non absolument pas non et c'est ce
que je dis aussi à mes collègues c'est
ce que je dis aux jeunes quand je donne
quelques quelques cours à l'école
supérieure de journalisme je pense que
tout arrive à point pour qui sait
attendre et quand le fruit doit tomber
il tombe mais si c'est derrière pour
dire voilà dans trois ans je me fixe au
sein je vais de champion l1 etc c'est le
meilleur moyen de se casser la gueule
pendant l'agression mais moi je pense
que la valeur c'est le sel c'est
vraiment celle du travail je m'imaginais
pas une seule seconde devenir patron des
sports de canal patron d une première
aujourd'hui maire de poissy et je le
suis devenu il ya eu un concours de
circonstances ok mais moi je dois rien à
personne j'ai bossé avec mes collègues
on a eu un esprit d'équipé c'est comme
ça qu'on est devenu donc j'ai très bien
comme ça je suis ravie je suis
aujourd'hui porte paroles d'alain juppé
au niveau départemental on va en parler
la présentation de ses meetings je suis
ravi d'être aux côtés de ce monsieur un
mot peut-être de façon générale en
afrique quand on regarde un peu
l'histoire comme ça des élections sous
la vème république je passe je parle
devant vous stéphane c'est peut-être la
première fois qu'on a autant
d'incertitudes sur ce qui va se passer
le jeu est extrêmement ouvert ça c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant au
demeurant est peut-être d'angoissant et
d'angoissé d'un titre
disait parler avec des chefs
d'entreprise disent aimer comment voulez
vous que des entreprises étrangères
viennent en france aujourd'hui avec
l'incertitude politique qui règne c'est
vrai que ça pose des problèmes pas
d'accord non non je suis pas daccord
d'abord on l'a déjà connu en 2002 1 qui
eût cru que monsieur jose paribas serait
à ça c'était juste pour chirac en
français 95 inconnu au cinéma pathé live
balladur barry chirac un mail envoyé à
peu près qui serait moi j'ai pas la même
entre changy l'arabe est monsieur
claramunt c'est que aujourd'hui j'en
suis pas à me dire mais comment une
écurie étrangère une entreprise entraîne
je viendrai en france comme on peut
faire c'est plutôt qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour garder nos entreprises françaises
et c'est chez nous je vois le cas précis
on a souvent dit que psa allait à un
moment donné retire sa lettre le aulnay
du val de seine etc les relations avec
monsieur tavares et les équipes du site
de production et du pôle tertiaire de
poésie sont telles que le travail avec
le département des yvelines le conseil
départemental des yvelines avec la
communauté urbaine et la ville de poissy
fait que non seulement psa reste qu'il
km 135 millions dans le l'industrie et
qu'en plus on à 1500 cols blancs qui
viennent rejoindre fois ci la saison
prochaine une information que je vous
donne à partir de septembre donc ça veut
dire que quand on donne un tout petit
peu les moyens de dire aux gens venez
chez nous va bien on va créer les
conditions note pour pouvoir il faut
déjà penser à ça je pense qu'il faut
qu'on préserve le loup il en france
voilà et
parce que c'est vrai que les milieux
économiques grâce à beaucoup
d'incertitudes
c'est un faux problème ou alors on lève
tout de suite l'idée s'est fait là vous
avez une réponse qu'est ce qui fait que
on regardera plus les entreprises
françaises en matière grise partent à
l'étranger
enfin c'est vrai qu'il ya incertitude
sur sur ce qui va se passer on ne sait
pas encore qui sera vraiment con et 44
des primaires il ya pas bon en 95 en
2002 en fait on avait les candidats
qu'on attendait et qui a une surprise
randonnées sorties des urnes et enfin 95
aussi vous voyez la durée mais là le
problème c'est pas vrai mais une
incertitude même sur le nom des
candidats qu'on va retrouver finalement
au mois de mai de l'année prochaine puis
celle des primaires deux camps des deux
camps pro tête et donc je pense que en
termes d'insécurité eux
ce qui est vraiment dommage c'est que
cette se fait que les gens ne sachent
pas vraiment qui va émerger en novembre
et en décembre ou janvier les primaires
de gauche fait qu' il ya des notamment
marine le pen qui va commencer à sortir
du bois je pense d'ici quelques quelques
semaines va pouvoir surfer aussi sur les
peurs sur les angoisses sur les
problématiques d'insécurité en disant
pas pour l'instant en phase elle a beau
jeu d'y aller parce qu'on a tellement de
voir on va voir tellement de voix
dissonantes est de gens qui
malheureusement tel que c'est commencer
déjà sur les primaires aussi bien à
droite qu'à gauche à d'ailleurs avec
quand même un débat qui veulent quand
même relativement bon je trouve qu'ils
très décevant et je crois que les gens
sont un peu angoissés mais aussi parce
qu'il a commencé
bourgeois m par rapport à ce que vous
direz vous vous dites notamment sur
effectivement le l'existence même des
primaires moi je pense que si à droite
et au centre il ya un exemple apprendre
pardon de le dire mais peut-être le seul
exemple apprendre à gauche c'est
l'exemple de la primaire fait en 2011
par par la gauche qui était juste
exemplaires le problème à droite et dans
ce mouvement gaulliste c'est que c'est
un pas naturel c'est pas la culture un
peu bonapartisme fait qu il ya toujours
un adossement un chef un guide etc etc
aujourd'hui la difficulté et moi c'est
ma crainte c'est que je pense que la
scène des tontons flingueurs dans la
cuisine il faut s'arrêter tout de suite
parce que au soir là recoller les
morceaux à 3,28 le pulse alors leurs
collègues est amusant parce que quand
vous dites de la primaire socialiste est
exemplaire qui peut honnêtement dire à
l'heure actuelle que ça a été exemplaire
que ce soit françois hollande qui
sortent de ces primaires on estime que
la tenue des primaires a été exemplaire
les débats ont été bien les cathares et
l'importance mais ce qui compte dans une
primaire c'est le résultat c'est pas la
façon qui compte c'est que c'est que ça
accouche d'un jardin d'un candidat digne
de ce nom et qui puisse faire un
président digne de ce nom or là je ne
porte pas être le seul français je pense
que le président est à moins de 10 %
d'opinions favorables je pense qu'il ya
90 % des gens qui la vérité est coiffé
une scène bien sûr
[Musique]
pour moi c'est la preuve évidente que je
vous rejoindrai peut-être c'est que les
primaires pour gagner les primaires faut
être assez flou parce qu'il a été
rassemblé un peu trop confortable qu'il
faut pas prendre de positions trop trop
forte c'était alors que alors les gens
attendent des positions fortes alors il
est l'homme inquiet me mais recule
catastrophe c'est la fin des partis
politiques c'est la fin du militantisme
c'est là c'est la fin de beaucoup de
choses et moi je pense que c'est quelque
part la fin de la démocratie parce
qu'effectivement tout le monde va
s'engager jusqu'au dernier moment pour
que l' on devrait déjà savoir qui à
droite et qui à gauche va effectivement
relevé le gant mais là on sait pas et il
rompt s'engueuler justement pas pendant
13 d'éval la fin des parties afin situe
sans doute unis sein des partis
politiques c'est pas la fin parce qu'on
peut penser qu'ils ont la mainmise sur
les sur l'organisation des primaires il
leur donne et puis de surcroît on ne
sait pas encore comment faire semblait
parti politique je sais bien que les
partis ne sont pas en mauvaise image etc
on se flatte de ne jamais avoir
appartenu à certains partis à falaise
certains élus disent non sont les
parties j'en suis très éloigné etc mais
sauf que ce sont des institutions des
machines des mécanismes qui sont
inhérents la démocratie que
bon alors je sais bien macro voilà qui
n'est ni à gauche ni à droite un peu de
gauche mais sans être socialiste enfin
il faut pouvoir s'y repérer
pour voter oui j'aimerais comprendre
militants quel est l'intérêt pour un
coût de 2 d'aller au ps ou chez les
républicains pour militer ça ne sert
strictement à rien si ce n'est à perdre
du temps et a donné de son énergie parce
que de toute façon le premier clampins
venu pour aller voter aura autant
d'importance que lui donc le
militantisme et moi je suis là où je
suis absolument d'accord avec vous c'est
à dire que c'est aussi l'expression l'a
déjà évoqué deux d'une très grande
faiblesse des partis politiques la
fonction des partis politiques la
sanction besoin d'un parti s'est dégagée
des candidats
je voulais dire aussi c'est que ce qui
tue un peu aussi le débat c'est que ces
primaires là c'est une manne pour les
sondeurs enfin j'veux dire des sondages
on en a tous les jours
ça veut rien dire si on a des sondages
au jour parce que
c'est bien qu'il va aller voter au sort
des sondages extrêmement complexe qui
sont deux sk qui sont coûteux mais en
fait les maîtres du jeu aujourd'hui ce
sont les sondages puisque en fait on
attend les sondages tous les jours et
avec les primaires on rendra à voir tous
les jours jusqu'au mois de mai est très
simple c'est vers eux que le jeu n'est
sûr
sur l'explication donnée sur l'abandon
des partis aujourd'hui la france n'est
pas n'est pas un parti sinon ça se
saurait l'élection présidentielle c'est
pas celle de d'appareils d'appareil
politique c'est celle effectivement des
administrés et la primaire ce que je
pense qu'elle se rapproche le plus près
possible en tout cas de ce que peuvent
attendre les français à la différence de
l'appareil politique pure et dure si on
veut arrêter de parler de gauche et
droite du ps et de le dire de l'ump des
républicains il faut effectivement
abandonnés que la base
s'élargissent un petit peu c'est pour ça
que moi je suis relativement satisfait
que si on souhaite je pars dans deux de
prêcher pour ma paroisse mais si on
souhaite partir rassemblés
au sein du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle fait il faut
effectivement dépassé cela est que à
partir du 28 ce soit tous derrière un
seul homme et j'ai presque envie de dire
quels qu'ils soient donc on reviendra à
ce qu'on dit ici qu'on n'a pas connues
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas très
naturel alors voilà on voit les
candidats rien n'a beaucoup
donc je vais m'en restait 8 il en
restait alors
nathalie kosciusko morizet dit qu'elle a
eues ces images hervé mariton dit qu'il
les a eu aussi donc on verra exactement
qui sont les conduire en gros il y en a
quand même deux qui se détache c'est
c'était un super et c'est nicolas
sarkozy justement ben là je paye t h à
toulouse y étiez d'ailleurs vous le
soutenez donc on va en parler après on
regarde un peu un reportage sur son
passage à chatou
pour nous c'est le vrai lancement
aujourd'hui cela c'est vrai démarrage de
ces primaires pour sa rentrée politique
alain juppé et son équipe ont choisi les
yvelines entouré de jean pierre raffarin
et de gérard larcher le candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre a
tenu un meeting à chatou le 27 août
dernier un déplacement placé sous le
signe du dialogue avec les français et
les représentants des collectivités
locales
je m'appuie beaucoup sur les élus locaux
sur les berges voire des milliers que
j'ai beaucoup rencontrés tout au long de
ces deux années je suis moi-même mer
donc on se parle
le collègue collègues comme je le dis
souvent ils sont un peu l'ossature de la
république qui sont toujours en première
ligne vis-à-vis de leurs concitoyens à
leur grande force c'est précisément
cette proximité que vous évoquez et
alain juppé compte de nombreux soutiens
dans le département avec dans leurs
rangs des élus yvelinois c'est une bonne
chose aussi parce qu'une grande
manifestation républicaine pour la ville
de chatou on en parle on parlait jusqu'à
présent des impressionnistes pour son
pôle culturel maintenant on va en parler
pour le jour 1 de l'accession au pouvoir
d'alain juppé j'espère
en avril 2017 et le pacte gagnant
gagnant qu'il propose avec les élus de
terrain qui sont finalement les
personnes les plus proches de nos
administrés me va bien pour l'équipe
d'alain juppé les meetings se poursuivre
les candidatures pour la primaire
doivent être déposées avant le 9 pour le
début de la campagne officielle prévue
le 21 septembre
vous étiez à chatou auprès d'alain weill
donc vous êtes ton porte parole dans le
dans le département
c'est un choix que vous avez fait il ya
longtemps d'ailleurs - patrick g une
formule 1 on n'attend pas l'arrivée
d'être chaude l'arrivée du tiercé pour
donner l'heure des chevaux et donc en
décembre 2013 j'ai fait la rencontre de
feu de monsieur juppé à bordeaux j'ai
beaucoup aimé le lien direct qu'il
pouvait avoir avec les futurs élus que
j'étais donc avec avec les maires et moi
entendre quelqu'un de sa stature dire
mon projet pour la france je vais
m'adosser comme colonne vertébrale vers
les mers ça me parle le contrat gagnant
gagnant dont il parle en disant voilà il
faut baisser les les finances publiques
et pour cela c'est à la fois les des
dépenses publiques mais aussi un contrat
gagnant gagnant si les maires gère bien
les deniers publics qui aura moins de
baisses de dotations ça ça nous parle
c'est un contrat gagnant-gagnant et
quelque chose quelque chose qui moi me
parle personnellement c'est
l'apprentissage c'est un fervent
défenseur de l'apprentissage aujourd'hui
en france on a à peu près je regarde le
genre le monsieur le professeur on a à
peu près 500 milles apprentis en
allemagne à un million cinq cent mille
apprentis on a un taux de chômage dans
cette classe d'âge de 18 25 ans à peu
près qui chez nous est à peu près à 25%
elle est à moins de 10% en allemagne
donc le losc à la différence de ce qu on
dit que c'est une voie par défaut
l'apprentissage pour moi pour nous pour
monsieur juppé ces équipes c'est un
passeport pour l'emploi donc là il ya
des choses concrètes qui qui sont faites
puis après oui c'est un homme d'état il
a l'expérience il n'y a pas de clivage
il ya un rassemblement qui est fait
c'est l'homme d'un mandat donc il y aura
des réformes il annoncera la couleur moi
qui viens du sport on a imbibé encore
une fois aux règles du jeu c'est quelque
chose qui me parle je suis pas le seul
il ya l'appel aux mille mère d'emilie
mère qui était présent et qui sont
derrière lui et autant de facteurs qui
fait que au delà du lien personnel qu'il
crée avec les gens de terrain il ya cet
engouement et on le voit pardon de le
dire dans les sondages jour après jour
mais aussi sur le terrain parce que ça
c'est plus important
qui nous parle à nouveau le dit et c'est
vrai c'est un homme d'état il a été
premier ministre il est vous le
rappeliez maire de bordeaux et tout le
monde reconnaît alors droite et gauche
confondues que c'est un excellent maire
de bordeaux qu'il a changé le visage de
la ville est-ce que vous pensez que
l'expérience qu'on a à la tête d'une
mairie elle est transposable à la tête
d'un état même si les problèmes sont
différents oui enfin il était ministre
avant d'être maire de gérer il avait été
promu miss mai mais c'est vrai que là
premier ministre n'a été compté un
premier ministre contesté il est un
maître incontesté si je peux dire et
d'ailleurs il se sert de son expérience
bordelaise pour dire voilà c'est aussi
un peu ce que je veux faire pour la
france ac je pense et ce que celle
transposable je pense que de bons crus
et là puis là-bas on est à bordeaux vous
sais de quoi je parle oui et puis et
puis en tout cas c'est clair on assez
clair dans la proche qui est qui est la
sienne sur c'est sur ces économies que
nous devons faire pour baisser 7,7 est
énorme et notamment les remboursements
d'emprunts un exemple on parlait tout à
l'heure des collèges mais sur les
rythmes scolaires cette loi encore une
fois qu'ils étaient imposées du haut
vers le bas sans concertation qui ne
satisfait personne et qui est impactée
auprès des auprès des maires à possible
par exemple ces neuf cent mille euros
par an avec les aides d'état qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas un fossé énorme
c'est un million deux cent mille au ca
ne satisfait personne alain juppé dit
fier des communes vers lesquels les
rythmes scolaires fonctionnent ils
pourront continuer mais si certains
maires souhaitent revenir à ce qui
existait auparavant reviendra auparavant
je pense que c'est très pragmatique et
aujourd'hui centralisation on en a
dedans mais aujourd'hui on a besoin de
pragmatisme et de bon sens tout
simplement
alors vous êtes donc on allait
intervenir à tous
non c'est presque paraître sarkozy
si vous êtes maire de poissy et alors
vous êtes juppé de dire mais vous avez
quand même accueilli nicolas sarkozy qui
venait
juste après sa déclaration de
candidature on regarde le reportage peut
on en parle tout à fait
comme si de rien n'était il serre des
mains fédé selphy signe des autographes
fun nicolas sarkozy était dans les
yvelines pour parler éducation après une
table ronde à orgeval avec des
professeurs d'école elle s'est rendue à
poissy pour dédicacer son livre tout
pour la france l'occasion pour l'ancien
président de la république de mesurer le
soutien indéfectible de ses partisans
aucun doute aucun doute je toujours
confiance en lui je le soutiendrai
jusqu'en 2017 je veux l'aider on peut
tous les désirs et si on rassemble et
français où rim on peut les lire
je vois pas qui d'autre peut nous sortir
de ce guêpier dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui entre les attentes des
attentes à calais le social qui nous
prend un argent monstrueux aujourd'hui
les subventions des communes qui
disparaissent comme
neige qui fond au soleil voilà donc je
pense qu'il ya que monsieur sarkozy oui
aujourd'hui franchement qui peut faire
quelque chose pour la france soutient
également du côté des élus locaux alors
que nicolas sarkozy a vu son agenda
judiciaire se remplir en début de
semaine avec l'annoncé de son éventuel
renvoi devant le tribunal dans l'
affaire des comptes de campagne vous
savez les les comptes de monsieur jospin
n'était pas exacte on le sait maintenant
monsieur dumas raconter ça et le conseil
constitutionnel a préféré regarder
ailleurs ça a été la même chose pour les
comptes de monsieur balladur
cette histoire de comptes de campagne ça
me paraît être un péché véniel les gens
font la part des choses faut arrêter de
penser que les gens ne sont pas capables
de voir ne sont pas capables de voir
les mêmes ficelles les câbles que
tendent
la majorité actuelle pour entraver la
route même vers la présidence calme
serein devant une salle acquise à sa
cause le président des républicains a
tenu à rassurer s'il en était encore
besoin ses partisans rien ne l'empêchera
d'être candidat
aucune polémique
aucune manoeuvre
aucune manipulation haution 2 soit elle
ne me détournera d'un centimètre de ma
volonté absolue de construire avec vous
une alternance forte une alternance
frosch une alternance perceptible par
tous les français avant la présidence
nicolas sarkozy devra passer par la case
primaire les candidats officiels seront
connus le 9 septembre pour une élection
les 20 et 27 novembre prochains
voilà rien ne le détournera gens savent
où est donc ravi
très content pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord ce que je pense vraiment mais
très très profondément que c'est le seul
rempart au front national c'est sarkozy
je pense que c'est vraiment absolument
indéniable une première chose
deuxièmement je vois avec plaisir ce son
bouquin honnêtement je ne vais pas lui
mais près de 200000 exemplaires vendus
en quasiment 12 jours c'était
extraordinaire
ça montre qu'il ya quand même alors quoi
de savoir se montrer autre chose et
c'est pas du tout une attaque contre
votre protégé mais jp en est déjà à son
troisième ou quatrième mais si on
additionne les trois ou quatre bouquins
on n'arrive pas la moitié de ce qu'a
vendu sarkozy donc voilà non mais je ne
sais pas du tout il faut en tirer comme
conclusion mais visiblement sarkozy
voilà un peu besoin enfin il ya un
besoin de sarkozy alors jean charles
vite vous affirmer de manière
péremptoire que sarkozy est le seul
rempart contre marine le pen sans
argumenter mais pourquoi lui pourquoi
pourquoi ce serait le seul super ne
pourrait pas être un rempart contre
marine le pen je ne voulais pas
forcément mettre le
débat là dessus mais moi quand j'entends
juppé à propos de voile qui on va le
voile on peut en discuter ma mère
portait le voile pour aller à l'église
pour moi tout est dit c'est à dire que
là je veux dire c'est sont des flots de
gens qui vont aller vers le front
national si c'est ça la droite si la
seule réaction l'un est lui fut-il
premier ministre est très brillant maire
de bordeaux c'est à dire que la réponse
au voile c'est sa mère qui allait à
l'église avec
maria compris la rapport par rapport à
ça je pense que c'est parce que ce que
dit monsieur juppé notamment concernant
le burqini il dit simplement et on pense
simplement et moi je le vois à poissy à
30 % de notre population qui est une
population d'origine étrangère c'est que
aujourd'hui focalisée sur le burqini et
uniquement sur le burqini et dire on
fera des remarques à ce moment là on va
faire un code civil de de la garde-robe
aujourd'hui c'est le burqini ensuite
mettons que demain est quelqu'un qui
vient djellaba sur la plage pour la
hauteur 0 jeudi c'est juste pour
terminer je dis simplement maintenant si
effectivement il ya des appropriations
communautariste provocatrice sur les
plages comme on l'a vu encore n'y a
aucun cadeau à faire et c'est ce que dit
alain juppé maintenant chez moi ici
après si on a une charte de la laïcité
qu'on a mis en place depuis 2014 et ça
se passe bien ça se passe bien avec tout
avec tous les cultes parce que d'abord
on se rencontre on dit les choses il ya
des règles et on applique les règles et
je le redis si on applique les règles
qui aura bien moins de problèmes dans ce
pays mais sont tout à fait d'accord à
l'évidence poissy est un laboratoire et
un bon laboratoire mais regret c'est
qu'on sait très bien que ça se passe pas
comme ça dans toute la france n'y a pas
une journée on voit pas d'aider des
nanas en short qui se font agresser
parce que c'est pas la bonne tenue des
ddd nana la sortie de l'école ont vu
qu'on traite de parce qu'elles sont
elles sont passées mais ne sont pas
assez vêtu
conclure qu'il sait faire le nom mais
c'est faire le jeu des terroristes c'est
ça qu'ils attendent isa temps divise à
ce qu'on éclate la france c'est ça qui a
fait le plein des arguments ces mots
nous ne disons rien ne disons rien
contre les dérives de l'islamiste parce
que sinon ça fait le jeu de l'islamisme
bombe à ce moment là on laisse tomber on
a besoin d'un bikini c'est normal il
ya trois ans il avait un seul souci sur
une plage en france non mais mais
justement tant déçu je sais juste que
ces notations
à une provocation il faudrait avant tout
remercier baltard fait pas sans heurt
mature il faut passer un week-end risque
est quand même consternant c'est que
vous dites sarkozy elle rempart contre
le front national - voyez cet été j'en
étais presque à me dire que le front
national sera le dernier rempart contre
sarkozy parce que tout de même sur la
mesure d'un bon ou non mais c'est pas un
bon mot sur la sur la question
fondamentale
de l'état de droit je trouve que juppé a
été sans doute l'un de ceux qu'a eu le
discours peut-être pas le plus audible
mais en tout cas le plus intelligent
entendre entendre un ancien président de
la république qui se permet d'affirmer
lui et les siens que finalement les
questions constitutionnelles
ce ne sont que des arguties juridiques
que les juristes entre autres guillemets
sont des empêcheurs de tourner en rond
et des emmerdeurs etc il a raison ils
sont là pour ça et heureusement qu'ils
sont là pour ça face à des à des élus
qui sont prêts à aller aussi loin et
dans le même temps en temps de marine le
pen qui dit c'est pas possible on ne
peut pas mettre en cause cette ce
concept fondamental sur lequel pardon
mais l'occident s'est construit quand
même depuis 12 115 la grande charte la
magna carta en grande bretagne sur
lequel notre ordre démocratique et
républicain s'est construit tout au long
du 19e siècle et on dit ben non il faut
il faut adapter le droit la constitution
sont des arguties la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme bas il
suffit d'en sortir un état comme la
turquie n'ose même pas en sortir
unis mais il faut en sortir aussi parce
que tout ça
arrive pour cent des voix vous serez le
premier à pleurer ah oui c'est peut-être
un petit peu dommage notamment on aurait
dû siège chez elle concerne pour pas
qu'on soit sur ces deux extrêmes c'est
que en faisant en sorte de bien
expliquer les choses la charte de la
laïcité c'est quelque chose qui pour moi
est très important nous avions apprécié
comme d'ailleurs ailleurs des
assistantes maternelles par exemple qui
portait le voile est compris dans les
sites publics on a mis fin à ça en
expliquant simplement les choses en
expliquant ce qu'était la laïcité on
expire la charte de la laïcité en
adossant les chars de la licité aux
demandes de subventions etc il ya dix
points de moins entre 10 et 20 points de
moins apprécié du front national par
rapport aux villes lille benoît que
c'est très long que je pense c'est donc
je rejoins ce que ce que vous dites je
pense que ça ça fonctionne ensuite de
grâce attention attention à ne pas
mélanger les genres sur le terrain sur
le terrain les gens sont très loin de
toutes ces considérations purement
politique qui consiste à se flinguer les
uns les autres un de gauche comme de
droite sur le terrain que nous montons
de la sécurité du pouvoir d'achat
d'arrêter quand on est chef d'entreprise
d'être pris à la gorge parce que les
taxes deux fois parfois trois fois
supérieur à l'extérieur et ça je pense
que c'est la priorité ensuite voilà il
ya le burqini moi je pourrais vous
donner un exemple qui vient du football
où il ya encore aller une dizaine
d'années quand on prenait une douche on
était tous tout nu sous la douche vous
savez combien on est aujourd'hui
personne n'est venu sous le départ est
une seule je suis le seul nu comme
d'autres parce que parce que les
musulmans se baignent qu'elles sont
parce que le converti à l'islam semaine
en caleçon et parce que le catholique
comme vous et moi fais comme tout le
monde voilà ça c'est aussi c'est un
problème ça aussi c'est un problème et
pourtant il n'y a pas de difficultés
donc s'il faut créer un code civil oui
lors de la garde-robe ça en devient
insupportable
d'où l'idée au delà de tout ça c'est ce
que font les talibans à celle d'ali
bongo qui dit il faut tailler longueur
d'onde d'alain juppé de d'avoir une
gérer un code de bonne conduite il est
temps qu'on ait un code de bonne
conduite et qu'on perd pas d'objectif en
tout cas à droite que la primaire n'est
que voilà n'est qu'une opposition et que
c'est pas un combat est évidemment il
parce qu'il faudra pas se tromper de
contrer le 21 mai sur les parce qu'on
est à peine deux minutes d'un mot sur
les yvelines comme qui alors
vous remplacez la corrèze dans le
département qui donne des des chefs
d'état qu'est-ce qu'on a quand même
quatre candidats afin quatre prétendants
il y avait hier donc poisson qui sera
candidat puisqu'il est il est là
exigeons culturelles du sénat myard qui
ne le sera probablement pas henri guaino
qui dit qu'il se présentera malgré les
logiques qui sera pas toléré mer mais
qu'il souhaitait être candidat à la
présidentielle où ils vont chercher 500
parrainages par les mâles et et
à bon et benoît hamon avec ce que vous
avez une ville de nom de son micro parti
qui s'appelle bis
alors je ne sais pas comment ils ont des
communicants ces gens là ou pas
de les emprunter au long de cette course
est une année c'était je pense qu'ils
ont tous pensé à la divinité grecque et
ne pas voir ce que ça faisait quand même
pas difficile à prononcer
la branche plats bio ça se fait qu'ils
ont autant de
18 mois parmi les jets pas ça fait
monter plus la tête dans les yvelines
ils sont tenus de dire depuis port pour
en revenir à benoît hamon je ne partage
pas la très grande majorité de ces
dîners en revanche c'est quelqu'un qui a
des convictions c'est quelqu'un qui sait
où il va c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
dévié par rapport à l'image qu'il se
faisait du sens politique qui
souhaitaient à donner à la gauche et
parfois la gauche de la gauche et c'est
quelqu'un qui pour moi dans les yvelines
est quelqu'un de respectable respectable
a échangé pendant longtemps qu'elle des
objets rendus s'élève et avait la
légitimité pour se présenter aux
élections présidentielles on a
l'impression que maintenant tout le
monde dans mes pantalons ça parle de la
zambie à la primaire il avait faire boum
tas je viens donc il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils se présentent pas la primaire de
gauche chez prévert de manger bien et je
suis pas avocat de gauche
merci en tout cas karl olive je rappelle
le titre de votre livre ma ville ma
bataille et la politique c'est ici c'est
chez balland
merci florence mercadé merci stéphane
minson merci jean charles johnny on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau pas
[Musique]